[Musique]
pas un lieu de culte ça ses finances en
règle générale par les fidèles de la
mosquée 1 on fait le tour de nos fidèles
ont fait le tour des musulmans qui se
trouvent autour de la mosquée on leur
parle du projet et on leur demande un
financement et c'est chacun par rapport
à ces c'est à ces ressources par rapport
à son salaire par rapport à ces à ces
économies qu'ils décident de faire un
don pour le projet et c'est comme ça en
général qu'on confie dans une mosquée la
mosquée de strasbourg c'est une mosquée
qui est un peu plus grande que les
autres mosquées dont on a l'habitude de
construire donc les donateurs d'un
mosquée
son centre est généreux mais comme le
prendre le projet il est il est assez
grand
il ya les colloques aux dents à côté de
la mosquée id à sa bibliothèque
il y à son centre de recherche il y à
son petit restaurant son prix centre
commercial le musée où on va parler un
peu de l'islam ou des musulmans arrivée
en france et c'est donc ça demande un
peu plus de subventions et comme nous
sommes dans une zone concordataire où on
a le droit de demander une subvention à
la municipalité à la région et au
département
donc nous avons vous à dire utiliser ce
droit pour refaire une demande à la
municipalité et nous sommes en train
d'envoyer les demandes aussi à la région
est fortement un projet de 25 millions
c'est quand même lourd
alors hier il ya les fidèles c'est sûr
il y à la subvention de 10 pour cent de
la ville de strasbourg il ya les deux
fois 8 % qui peuvent effectivement aussi
alimenter le la caisse de la part du
conseil européen d'alsace et qu'on le
conseil régional de racheter mais ça ne
fait on est on est à 24 % et 26 %
pendant excusez moi et effectivement il
ya quand même 60 74 % qui restent alors
là je pense que ça va être très
difficile c'est un grand projet mais
qu'il n'est absolument pas nouveau si ça
fait très longtemps que les lits les
locaux existent et que effectivement il
ya un moment
ce projet était déjà dans les cartons il
ya je ne sais pas que ces seuils ne me
contredira ou pas je la mets café ou
presque une vingtaine d'années je pense
qu'il ya ces locaux alors c'était
effectivement des bâtiments un peu de la
distillation diverses et puis le projet
est né à ce moment là et c'est vrai on a
un projet qui ont reçu ce combat jusqu'à
dimanche et celles qui ont reçu de la
plupart des projets ou date de
réalisation
du bellay gruchet jusqu'à maintenant en
france nous sommes une association qui
s'implantent est à strasbourg dans les
années 1970 et jusqu'aujourd'hui on a
toujours financé nos mosquées nos locaux
avec l'argent de nos fidèles comme l'a
dit monsieur godard encore une fois le
financement étranger n'est pas interdit
mais malgré ça malgré ça nous n'avons eu
aucune aucun financement étranger donc
aucune subvention étrangère non plus je
ne sais pas si je les ai ratées ou
quelqu'un d'autre ait reçu la subvention
en notre nom
mais nous on en a pas reçu en tout cas
et concernant la convention d'istanbul
qui est annulé croyez moi personne n'a
demandé un mono vie et la vie de notre
fédération
même si nous sommes contre à l'islam
politique aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
le centre de la politique et nous sommes
la victime de cela risque c'est du soft
power en soi est ce que c'est
oui bien sûr c'est du soft power il est
indéniable que l'action du président à
l'attention que porte le président
ardoines à ce projet est très lié
effectivement à ce qu' il faut faire
comme effectivement c'est un peu plus
compliqué en allemagne parce que les
relations je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails
entre le le mégot ruche où la diana qui
le type qui est là la diane est quel
organe officiel du club turc et les
autorités allemandes sont un peu tendus
pour un certain nombre de raisons bon
alors qu'en france effectivement à
strasbourg bon il sait qu'il était
parfaitement évident que le climat
apparaît c'est beaucoup plus serein par
rapport à l'absence de cette mosquée
mais le contexte a changé
ah ah
une menace qui sera ouvert qu'aux
musulmans comme toutes les mosquées qui
sont ouverts à tous ouvert à tout public
donc avec son musée bibliothèque avec
tous et toutes ses activités parce que
saddam à tout le monde musulman chrétien
juif athée ou toute autre religion
ce serait une mosquée qui est ouvert à
tout le monde donc ça va être une
mosquée qui va prêcher le vivre ensemble
et former les jeunes de demain
sur le plan symbolique c'est strasbourg
aussi alors donc du coup il ya quelque
chose de très important en plus c'est
comme il l'a dit mais c'est faire qui
marque la présence si vous voulez des
musulmans turcs en france voire même en
europe
c'est à dire c'est un bâtiment qui a une
signification non seulement au niveau de
la région au niveau donne mais aussi au
niveau européen
parce que voyez d'ailleurs amusé il va y
avoir un certain nombre de réalisations
des sites culturels qui sont tus montre
l'ambition de ce projet